a taliban bomb ravaged the body of one
of the soldiers inside this vehicle in
afghanistan
the 2010 attack left andy inward with
mental as well as physical injuries
at his lowest point he thought about
taking his own life
sometimes in when i'm at home
and i get into the dark places i can
see my family just my kids and all that
and i've sometimes i'm like i'm a bit of
a hindrance to my family now finding out
what's going on in afghanistan it just
just makes me feel worse
andy is worried about the toll britain's
exit from afghanistan will have on
others
suicide rate for veterans it was high as
it was
i lost a friend
about a year ago now
devastated and i was before all of this
pulling out of afghan
and
this
the suicide rate is gonna
it's gonna rock it
he's concerned in particular about two
friends
it's difficult to
words
when you're trying to speak to them
especially when you've got your own
problems in a way is
sometimes the only thing you can do is
suggest they go speak to a counselor
a leading charity says news of the
taliban's victory in afghanistan has
triggered symptoms of post-traumatic
stress disorder or ptsd in veterans
across the uk
combat stress has received more than
double the normal rate of weekly phone
calls since kabul fell with more than
400 in the last week of august
now that they're back here and hearing
everything that's going on
they're confused if it was so important
why did we pull out so quickly so there
is a there is an absolute confusion we
call that moral injury they're really
concerned about about
why they were there what they achieved
while they were there
in a strange twist sky news understands
the military spy agency defense
intelligence has launched an
investigation into an alleged suicide
note from a veteran amid concerns it
could be a hoax
concern about suicide risks though all
too real
the government the nation needs to put
our arm around our veterans and tell
them how proud we are of what they did
and make sure that we separate whatever
anger people feel about the political
decisions
for andy though he says veterans still
need more government help during these
difficult days
debra haynes sky news